it was a 124 word post on instagram and
if you read between the lines there's
still fire florence did not directly
mention olivia wilde harry styles spit
gate or the rumored feud which
overshadowed their venice film festival
premiere
she did include a special shout out to
the internet's favorite man in the
middle co-star chris pine quote how cute
and hilarious chris pine is for being
the number one photographer love you
chrissy we try to control our chaotic
environment there's certainly issues
there and when it comes to this little
nickname i think this might be a bit of
a wake-up call for miss flow florence's
glam squad rocked custom miss flow
t-shirts as she unleashed a massive grin
et has learned she will skip the film's
next press event in new york september
19th keep calm
and carry on now to the means
[Applause]
fans have uncovered this video showing
harry seemingly turning his back on
olivia andy cohen says he is in on
hosting a don't worry darling cast
reunion i want to talk about the love
bubble and co-star nick kroll posted
this hilarious video showing his place
in the media storm not harry not olivia
not florence
[Music]